all right we're back sorry about that uh
i was actually on my phone when i was
usb tethered on that but apparently that
was not working out for whatever yeah it
stopped for some reason i don't know if
it ran out of data or i don't really
know yeah so
we went back to the home system
uh so hopefully this will work because
[ __ ] man i feel like i've only got like
halfway through yeah holy crap it's
green since connection's good
everything's going so
yeah for now right i don't trust it i
just don't yeah whatever so yeah so what
were you talking about
uh mathias says why y'all didn't miss
anything as soon as that [ __ ] went
[ __ ] sideways well yeah i can see the
little on on obs i can see the little
green light going to like red and yellow
and i'm just like oh [ __ ] i'm not saying
anything important now so right now so
y'all didn't miss anything yeah
we got matthias said uh why oh he
retracted it but he said why is another
mess why another episode it's like yeah
our connection crapped out so we just
like they're telling me to [ __ ] get
the wigs out okay it must be time for a
wig look oh it's too bad that you don't
yeah you should you need to get the
[ __ ] white wig yeah yeah i was gonna
say the wig's way up there jeff
we'll get it right
i tried to put the ones that you wore
more often like at
down low and then i had to put some up
there because i only have so much room
she's got a whole dressing room in here
now yeah okay i'm liking i got a whole
little like [ __ ] situation i'm gonna
put my [ __ ] ultimate white boy wig
there you go i put on i put this on and
all of a sudden i become even more
caucasian
i become a real honkey
yeah there we go
damn
damn
you're gonna you're gonna like
pontificate on something like this
smarter and more powerful when i have
this on you gotta put some glasses on
too you'll look like
yeah look like some [ __ ] george
washington yeah yeah i'm ready to
[ __ ] emancipate some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's gonna embassy
some [ __ ] [ __ ] proclamation
proclamation little girl hanging down
yeah proclamation see you'd have a whole
outfit to go with that you need a whole
like frock coat
i have one you need the tights and the
buckle shoes you need i don't have shoes
i don't i don't you need the shoes the
short pants yeah with the stuff little
breeches yeah the breeches that make
your calves look good and [ __ ] that's
what we're saying how sexy a man was
with how good his calves were why don't
dudes wear that [ __ ] anymore i'm into
that
no that's okay what is this in here
something's in here i don't know look at
this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] was that dude no that's from the
uh that's from the wig stand okay
you pulled it off along with the wig
stand all right i have if you go on
amazon they have these really cool
they're only like a couple bucks each
they have these little wig stands that
either they're plastic and like you snap
them together and they'll they'll either
like sit on a table top or they have
ones that like hang like in your closet
which is very helpful
um
that's that's not
this is [ __ ] totally wrong rock me
out dude what happened tonight
what happened to this wig i'm gonna have
to [ __ ] get the curls going on that
[ __ ] again are you just gonna be back
there doing that it's gonna be so
distracting yeah no we can't do it go
ahead and run with the show
this thing's supposed to have two curls
here
girl there and a curl there you gotta
like do maintenance on the [ __ ] i just
you figure it out you figure it out
go ahead so what were you talking about
we're talking about lord byron
so so yeah so he was married uh in 1815
and they had a daughter aydah
fun fact this daughter who was actually
taken away from byron probably uh
justifiably so like very early
by his wife
well it was a baby well honestly i
wouldn't put it past lord it's like oh
it's a baby that's a sexy baby yeah
right
i mean
you know i'm sorry
yeah well um this baby would turn out
when she grew up
to be the very famous ada lovelace who
many years before the computer was
actually invented actually came up with
a theoretical
computer really in 1843 ada lovelace so
uh you know look her up it says lord
byron's uh
daughter there you go
uh so yeah
so uh basically lord byron and his wife
they had the kid uh they were only
married for like a year and then his
wife was like yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
left with the daughter
uh because at this point lord byron had
also started porking his uh half sister
which the wife was understandably a
little upset about so she's like
basically i'm taking this kid away and i
don't want you to have anything to do
with this kid ever uh so she
actually raised the kid to be a
mathematician and like i said the kid
would be uh ada lovelace mathias said
this is the omega man family coat wig
is from the omega man i like that yeah
my dice yeah
so uh in the spring of 1816 lord byron
uh you know because of this scandal
he uh decided he was going to get the
[ __ ] out of dodge uh in this case
england because everyone was kind of
pointing their fingers at him calling
him a hoe or whatever or whatever the
equivalent was
so he ended up going to geneva in
switzerland now while he was there
uh he got into like i said he was
hanging out with
uh percy shelley mary godwin and claire
claremont like i said claire claremont
was trying to get uh on that dick
so they were all kind of like and lord
byron was like okay i'll accept your
vagina but he was kind of more
interested in this whole percy shelley
mary wilson craft godwin situation
um i don't know like i don't know if he
wanted like a threesome or a foursome i
don't know it was kind of one of those
things
uh interestingly at this time period
when lord byron and percy shelley and
mary godwin and all them like hooked up
or were all hanging out together um at
the time like society at large called
them the league of incest
yeah they're thinking like i'm thinking
that's how i [ __ ] which that needs to
be a band name league of insane it
sounds like a like a bunch of super
villains
with a league of incidents
i guess because byron was humping his
half sister everybody kind of knew about
it that's what they're talking about
yeah so it was kind of this whole yeah
it was this old [ __ ] she couldn't resist
or he couldn't resist forcing himself on
her i don't really know how old she was
at the time maybe she was willing i'm
not talking i'm pretty sure that was a
[ __ ] two-way street
they're like we're not that related
[Laughter]
this is spiritual
[Laughter]
but yeah so i mean lord byron like i
said didn't really have uh you know he's
like the uh not the original but
kind of a
one of the the textbook definition of
like a bad boy like instead of rock star
right so he didn't really have any
shortage of women wanting to jump on the
d right you know
so uh so yeah during 1816 uh he's
running off
in shame
to switzerland uh to kind of hide
and um so he invited what
i gotta get out of here i'm getting too
much [ __ ]
well i guess he didn't really like as
much [ __ ] as he was getting he couldn't
just be like [ __ ] all you [ __ ] i'm
just getting [ __ ] like nobody but i
guess he was bothered
yeah by the reputation that he was
getting he didn't want to be he didn't
want to be in the league of incest he's
in the league i don't want to be in the
league
so he started to become a little bit
like the marquis de sade
yeah he definitely has that kind of vibe
although i got a feeling that [ __ ] he
was cuter than the martin kid assad the
marquis that was ugly
well i mean for paintings i've seen of
lord byron he was a pretty dashing
[ __ ] and like i said at least
when he was young i've read um i read a
a book about this like a couple books
about this
and one thing i remember was that lord
byron they said he was super foxy when
he was younger very very dashing very
handsome but because he had and a lot of
kind of upper class like nobility had
gout at the time because of their
rich diets and indolence
generally
um i guess would uh so i think he had a
tendency to like pork out you know what
i mean so he kind of like got heavier
as time went on
although like i said neither he nor
shelley lived very long they died quite
young
so
i don't know if he just would have been
like a big like job of the hut when he
was older but i think he did like chunk
out like
they had very bad food quality back then
difference between carbohydrates
fats or proteins they just [ __ ] ate
whatever tasted good
and i'll tell you what tastes good it's
fat fat tastes good and carbs taste good
i even had a nutritionist tell me that
they're like look it's just like
humans are
uh you know through our evolutionary
history
we're designed to crave fat and sugar
yeah um that's just
how nature designed because we needed
calories like for most of our lives but
nowadays there's so much food everywhere
that it's like not that's not really a
good successful uh survival strategy
anymore you think that [ __ ] eating
chicken and all that that's great
until you have these [ __ ] on
performance enhancing drugs they're
eating nothing but chicken and broccoli
and they will tell you it drives them
[ __ ] crazy not to have [ __ ]
carbohydrates and fats
they're like you would think that
chicken and meat and beef would you
could live on that
uh
after a couple weeks you start craving
any kind of carbohydrate or any kind of
[ __ ] fat you're just like ah
yeah and you start getting well there's
there's a reason that hangry is a word
yeah i mean because and like i said
because for most of humans evolutionary
history
uh food was scarce yeah so you needed
something that was like very fatter you
sugar sugary or something like that
because it had a lot of calories because
that would sustain you
now that food is like ubiquitous and
it's very easy to get to at least in the
western world uh we're kind of hosed
yeah because it's like we want all this
stuff but it's like we don't need that
much food i was in the army [ __ ] we had
a bunch of island boys in there from
[ __ ] micronesia we had them from soma
we had them from samoa we had them from
hawaii
and [ __ ] it was the funniest thing in
the world [ __ ] you couldn't get those
[ __ ] to eat [ __ ]
lobster
lobster [ __ ] they give that [ __ ] away
for free at the bar i kind of feel like
that happened in new england a lot they
just kind of thought it was like trash
food because it was everywhere they said
dude man i could live off lobster and
they go no you couldn't [ __ ] we tried
to live on off a lobster [ __ ] i don't
remember that was micronesia or hawaii
and they're just like uh
they're just like no you can't you can't
after a while you just get so sick of
that we were [ __ ] spin spinning money
hand over fist to get spam because spam
wasn't lobster because it wasn't lobster
yeah i mean even the best food is gonna
get a little after a while you're like i
mean food you want barack man one time
when i was in egypt [ __ ] [ __ ] a
british [ __ ] army the british [ __ ]
army contractors [ __ ] had lobster day
and most [ __ ] wouldn't eat it
and me and a whole table of [ __ ] like
eight dudes sat there and [ __ ] must
have had 20 lobster tails a piece whole
soup bowls full of [ __ ] melted butter
god i thought i was in heaven god that
[ __ ] was good that does a little lobster
that sounds heavenly oh yeah it was all
southerners [ __ ] eating that [ __ ]
like it was crawfish we were lucky i
could eat my [ __ ] weight and lobster
brothers was like man you eat that it
looks like a bug it's like come on here
and eat this baby it is about you're
like oh and everything looks like a
roach delicious delicious brothers
unless they were southern
like i said i could eat my own weight in
lobster and or shrimp yeah i [ __ ]
love it
makes me want to go get some shrimp
maybe we should go to markets we should
get some
[Laughter]
we can shrimp some shrimp we'll go see
halloween kills tomorrow
stop by sam's and get one of them big
old [ __ ] bags of shrimp for [ __ ]
20 bucks i mean they usually have a
thing
with it yeah 30 big old [ __ ]
several [ __ ] two pound [ __ ] three
pounds of [ __ ] shrimp
commercial grade [ __ ] bags of shrimp
i'll cook that [ __ ] up [ __ ] with
some
potatoes i got those red potatoes and
we'll throw some [ __ ] corn yeah we'll
get some corn corn cobs in there
have a [ __ ] crawfish have a [ __ ]
shrimp boil
okay i'll make the i'll make the uh man
you're trying to get me fat again
i'll make the damn i'll make it although
that's all protein i'll tell you what as
long as you don't eat the best it's all
protein but i'll make the [ __ ]
cocktail sauce and everything yeah be
good
because i got that must i got that
prepared horseradish
all right i got that already
see that's how it happens people
that started that happens that's how it
happens well no it's you start
fantasizing and then you start planting
and then this [ __ ] happens the next
thing all i've had today was three fish
tacos either that you gotta get a koi
juan we'll go to koi that's what i
thought you meant maybe we'll go to koi
wan and just eat the [ __ ] all you can
eat [ __ ] because then there will be
probably
leftovers
better way to do it
that's a cheaper way to do it just go to
koi won and eat those all you can eat
shrimp yeah probably yeah all right so
what was i talking about okay league of
incest league of instances that's
awesome that's awesome that is like i
said it sounds like a bunch of like uh
like a tribe of like super villains yeah
the week of insist
[Laughter]
yeah they knew how to troll back then
so so yeah so lord byron so he's staying
in switzerland at this at this villa
right
and even before i think even before
percy and mary and claire got there i
think there was like a reputation so
you'd have like tourists you'd have like
locals in the area they were like
looking at the villa like through
telescopes and [ __ ] like that hoping
they'd see like some orgies and whatnot
because they thought okay i'm sure it
wasn't as exciting as they were
imagining but they thought all kind of
like crazy [ __ ] orgy [ __ ] was going
on in there and they just wanted a
glimpse of that yeah i was just saying
i'm sure there was probably like i mean
i'm sure they were all like on [ __ ]
opium and [ __ ] i'm sure there was fun
[ __ ] going on in there because lord
byron did like i said he uh he was a hit
with the ladies
and it he had kind of like a hippie
commune kind of vibe going on there like
younger people in the area he was famous
um and he had money so
you know so people would come there and
they would hang out he had drugs so
everybody would like come there and hang
out and they'd like you know do drugs do
opium whatever and get
probably get freaky so
i so i can kind of understand why he got
that reputation but i don't i don't know
if it's as exciting as people were like
making it out to be like it was like the
worst thing in the world but everybody
was like trying to get a glimpse of that
[ __ ] so it's like that's very very funny
so there's yeah there's all kind of
rumors like uh going around so hilarious
khan says what is this a 13 o'clock
emancipation
that's what i'm doing man i'm
emancipating i'm proclamating up in here
in the middle of the [ __ ] show he's
emancipating man
i'm getting red massive broccoli made up
in here go ahead cuz that's like that
[ __ ] judge from [ __ ] idiocracy
remember him
uh sort of we're gonna get a ruling up
in here
so yeah
so uh
as maybe anybody that knows the story so
lord byron had a friend slash
physician personal physician named john
polidori
he was also staying there i'm sure this
doctor he was a doctor
uh but also he was kind of like i kind
of feel like maybe drug supplier
um you know hang her on he was that kind
of doctor as well
yeah so yeah so an opium was
legal at the time it i don't know if it
was like real respectable but it was
legal no it was you could get it you
look at it
all drugs are okay and like i said i'm
kind of reading because i'm rereading
drude which took place of
a decade or two later than this
um and even though it's a fictional
story it's you know it's period accurate
and laudanum was
kind of seen as it was a little bit
illicit but it was legal
so it wasn't like acceptable necessarily
but
a lot of people did it you know what i'm
saying it was kind of like had this
weird kind of that was morphine right
morphine mixed with something else i
think right well laudanum was kind of
like opium you would put opium in wine
okay
um
in the novel druid which is about wilkie
collins who was a real dude he was a
real novelist made wine stronger and he
would apparently like what you were
supposed to do was you were put put a
couple drops of opium in your wine so it
was kind of like you know opium and
alcohol mixed together
but wilkie collins he had like gout and
stuff because he was kind of like um
you know he he was kind of an obese dude
later in his life
and uh so he would drink like glasses of
the [ __ ] which was way more than this
like
so he would just like drink glas like
two or three glasses a day yeah which is
way way more than the recommended heroin
junkie level yeah yeah yeah because he
was like uh apparently he justified it
at least in the novel by saying that
like he was in pain all the time because
of the gout and um so that was the only
thing that would make the pain go away
he'd feel pain when he sobered up
because he was [ __ ] hurting for that
[ __ ] oh that's
yeah much better now yeah oh all right
for three glasses of the [ __ ] which
normally i mean to a normal dude if you
hadn't like built up a tolerance that
would like kill you
but yeah so uh so yeah opm lauden big
kind of thing at the at the time
so uh so basically what happened so lord
byron is staying uh on in switzerland on
a uh in villa diodati which i believe is
still there
uh on lake geneva
and uh as i said taurus in the area
trying to like look in the windows
trying to get a glimpse of like some
orgies or something i don't know if they
ever saw anything but you know
now so he invites uh percy shelley mary
wilson craft godwin like i said they
were not she was not mary shelley at
this point legally and claire claremont
to stay with him over the summer of
1816. now at first i think there's like
a misconception that they were actually
all living at the villa dia dante that's
not actually the case percy mary and
claire uh were actually staying at
another they rented another house nearby
which is called the maison chapui
um but they would go over to the villa
diode and the claire at this point was
uh
getting the dicken from lord byron
and
possibly became pregnant at this point
uh sometime around this time too
so she was
one of the lord byron's many conquests
top chances at full chats that is
let's see it looks like uh top chat no
go to live stream
okay there we go get everybody in there
because i noticed there wasn't too many
chats going yeah well it's not always
yeah that was just kind of what came up
now the summer of uh 1816
if you don't know
was called the year without a summer
what had ended up happening was that in
the spring of the previous year in april
of 1815 there was a big ass volcano
mount tam tabora or taboro yeah um which
is in present day indonesia at the time
was the dutch west indies
so it erupted
and uh this was actually the largest
volcanic eruption sent in recorded
history since
uh 180
bce
so this is bigen
um
they they call i guess they have a
volcano explosivity index explosivity i
love that uh index
it it goes up to eight this one was a
seven so it was it was a big one
um so it blew up
uh 12 000 people approximately in the
immediate vicinity of the volcano were
immediately killed immediately
um and this volcano this volcanic
eruption had worldwide uh impact because
basically
the the soot all the [ __ ] from the
volcano uh essentially blocked out the
sun
uh for
a long time afterwards and so
caused global temperatures to plummet
which obviously made a lot of like crops
fail and like they had a bunch of other
uh yeah and here's the [ __ ] weird
thing man you got to put this [ __ ] in
perspective it's been a while since i
[ __ ] read
it's been a while since i read it but if
i remember correctly
that
singular eruption
put out more carbon into the atmosphere
in the entire 20th 20th century all that
one day
that's like it may have i'm not sure but
like i said it was it was a massive
massive volcanic explosion massive
they're like yeah uh [ __ ] live super
word it
basically a dwarfed industry
a dwarf industry and eventually they're
kind of regular
and if [ __ ] yellowstone blows it'll
be [ __ ] worse well we were talking
about that on the how to survive a
catastrophe show and zach was talking
about that i think that that was one of
the things he worried about because
that's kind of overdue
um if that blew yeah we'd be [ __ ] yeah
and uh it would be something like this
but y'all need to like sit back and
relax man ain't [ __ ] compared to nature
and
events like this have been going on
since the history of [ __ ] the planet
this
gigantic eruptions and [ __ ] asteroid
impacts
and [ __ ] solar flares that's what you
really have to worry about
if we get nature's gonna like actually
ass rape you much worse than any of
these
[ __ ] i worry about that more than
what stupid-ass people do yeah
ecological diseases
[ __ ] no man if yellowstone blows
it's not saying that we're toast it's
just that you'll be on a different
planet for your lifetime it will be uh
not fun pretty cold for your lifetime
and honestly like this eruption uh
sheila ann asked it's mount uh what's it
called mount tabora to borrow something
like that yeah in what's now indonesia
yeah it blew and like i said this was uh
the worst volcanic eruption since
180
bce yeah uh you know or ce rather not
bce
uh so like i said a bad one for you know
several thousand years there hadn't been
one like that uh killed twelve thousand
people immediately
and then
uh pretty much for a year more than a
year afterward
uh kind of [ __ ] up the weather
uh because all of the [ __ ] that was in
the air like i said blocked out all the
sunlight which has a lot of you know
domino effects you know like crops can't
grow the temperatures drop everything's
really cold like a couple of winters
yeah yeah so 1816 very famously called
the year without a summer for that very
reason because the summer of that year
of 1816 which like i said was more than
a year after the volcano erupted
um was basically really cold
uh and it just like [ __ ] rained and
it was just cloudy and dark like the
whole time it was like super gloomy yeah
uh which you know unprecedented it was
like a crazy and
which led to like like i said a bunch of
other things down the line there were
tsunamis obviously in the immediate
aftermath
but there were a lot of deaths after
that because of the crops failing um you
know because of freezing temperatures in
you know the summer when no one was
expecting it yeah all kind of [ __ ]
crap there's all kind of famine and
stuff that happened because this is kind
of a paranormal [ __ ] mystery unsolved
mystery and true crime
show i must mention because this is now
something we're
touching on this topic
there's a possibility
that the the legend
of [ __ ] atlantis
may have been because of a [ __ ]
volcanic eruption
um known as the end of the minoan
civilization they had a damn
island blow up very much the same way
that had them and no one's living on it
and the egyptians may have remembered
that as the end of atlantis
very plausible well i kind of feel like
you know as much as i think that like
the myth of atlantis that's obviously
like it's a super like advanced
civilization that disappeared beneath
the waves obviously that's [ __ ]
but
i do think that it's possible that it
was based in reality it is probably
based in reality like you said a
volcanic eruption like took down like an
island civilization yeah and then people
you know just ex exaggerated it over the
years the egyptians said that they were
super advanced they're getting that
information handed down to them to
people who are less advanced than the
egyptians
okay
so everything is about perspective it
was just a civilization
yeah people thought it was advanced in
comparison to them well i don't think
they were as advanced as the egyptians
people tend to blow stuff out like and
and the more like the story goes on like
as the years go on bigger and bigger
yeah then people just like add more
details and stuff like that so i'm not
saying that well it's just kind of like
we were talking about this before like
the whole [ __ ] biblical flood story
which was yes based on you know a story
that was from the epic of gilgamesh like
thousands of years before that but we're
not saying that that wasn't based on i
think that was based on probably like a
small relatively local event
but it just got like conflated into this
big like global [ __ ] like over the time
over the years some people have thought
that the epic of gilgamesh i.e the flood
story may have been based on that damn
same end of the minoan civilization
it might have been it might have been
that same because like i said for people
of that time it would have seemed like a
massive [ __ ] deal thing throughout
the and it's being passed down to the
surviving civilization and people are
going to add their own details to it
it's going to get bigger and bigger
they're going to put their own gods in
people's imagination sure that's just
what happens that's legend building
that's what yeah you got a super chat
thank you zack volcanoes are some of the
most fascinating beautiful and scary
things to wait a minute oop i can't see
the whole thing to me and i can say i
lost 20k in property when kilauea
erupted in 2018
yeah volcanoes scary like i said and you
brought up yellowstone like erupting and
yeah that's kind of probably we should
worry about what could be worse though
asteroid impact well yeah that would
obviously be worse people don't realize
that asteroids go nuclear and if it's
big enough
extremely nuclear enough
to look what they did to the dinosaurs
even though that didn't all happen in
one day over time it kind of
changed the dinosaur forever into birds
and that asteroid was only about the
size of a bus yeah
so you just
which is kind of scary
and and here's the thing they hit
regularly yeah all the time in
and in geological
geological scale to hit regularly it's
just that we don't live very long so it
seems like a long time every every few
20 30 million years a big one hits
yeah and like i said it doesn't really
have to be all that big no the one that
wiped out the dinosaurs like i said it
wasn't immediate it had happened over a
while but the one that they thought it
was about the size of a city if a
dinosaur one hit us that'd be the end of
your civilization yep and most of your
population be dead yep
not immediately it would take a few
years it would probably wipe out a lot
of people immediately yeah but it would
take a while to like get yeah because
civilization can't
start struggling under new environmental
conditions power production becomes
difficult economies start to suffer you
just can't support a modern sized
civilization they start starving they
start killing each other [ __ ]
warlords emerge to fight uh becomes
warlike things 300 years later you have
10 percent of the population
that's just how it goes yep
well yeah and so it's like interesting
to me that
this is really i don't know this is
something that always struck me about
the story is that this volcanic eruption
which happened essentially like half a
world away from switzerland
had such an impact on
our culture
just because of something that probably
nobody was thinking about at the time
because of this volcanic eruption which
killed all these people
and had this enormous environmental
impact
which caused the summer of 1816 to be
not
a summer at all
because of the because of the weather
um
it so happened that because lord byron
mary shelley percy shelley were staying
at villa diodati and normally they would
do outdoor [ __ ] like you would do if you
were spending summer somewhere they
would go out on
the boats and like go out on like
walking excursions and stuff but they
couldn't do any of that stuff because it
was like really cold and it just [ __ ]
stormed and rained the whole summer so
they were essentially um confined to the
indoors for extended periods of time so
they needed to find some ways to like
amuse themselves
so what they did
was uh yeah allegedly uh doing a bunch
of like opium and [ __ ] like that because
like you do
um having a bunch of philosophical
discussions and they started uh reading
to one another and in particular telling
each other ghost stories
now
they started reading from a collection
of german horror stories uh called which
have been translated into english uh
english title being phantasmagoriana
so they were reading to each other from
that
um so while they're reading it
um and you have to think too that there
was a bunch of like
sexual tension going on at this time too
because you have like percy and mary
who are they're not married yet at this
point but they're kind of like they have
a thing
uh mary is still kind of grieving
because of the you know the death of her
child
uh also
percy is probably likely [ __ ] claire
as well
byron is also [ __ ] claire uh so
there's all this kind of like there's
all this free love kind of [ __ ] flying
around so there's all kind of like [ __ ]
going on and like i said drugs ghost
stories who knows and they're trapped
inside they can't go outside so it's
kind of like a lot of tension going on
at the time
so there's uh also allegedly i don't
know if this is the case or not but this
is something that i read at a couple of
uh sources john polidori who was byron's
physician
uh also apparently kind of had the hots
for mary and she was not having it so
that was that kind of [ __ ] going on too
uh you know so there was that also percy
shelley seemed like he was going back
into drama queen mode again
and he was just feeling very like
oppressed and closed in and whatever
so they start reading uh to each other
from all these ghost stories the
atmosphere is getting all kind of creepy
everybody's like drugged up it's like
there's all this kind of it was like a
goth party gone horribly horribly wrong
so
one night in particular lord byron
starts reading
from samuel taylor coleridge's very
famous poem christabel
uh which is a rhyme of the ancient
marine he did as well yes he did yeah um
and actually i believe that mary shelley
i believe that her family knew samuel
taylor caller if i'm not i might be
remembering yeah i have to [ __ ] iron
maiden yeah he did do rome in the age of
america he's very very various
so uh yeah so they started reading
christabel
and uh so the whole thing about
christabel is that it's kind of like a
supernatural type of thing uh there's
kind of like this character in it called
geraldine who is a woman but is actually
like uh what do you like a lamia which
is kind of like a that's like a witchy
or like a flying serpent
like a vampire
sort of like a supernatural kind of
creature kind of a siren
yeah or like a snake like like almost
like a medusa i want to say like a
medusa kinda that kind of it's that kind
of
thing so it's like a supernatural it's
like a horror poem
um so basically
percy shelley like i said drama queens
you guys
percy shelley apparently got really
uh
affected by this particular reading
and started having these
uh
overwhelming visions
of a woman
who had eyes instead of nipples
like eyes where her nipples would be
yeah and he was like super freaked out
by this
and probably the opium was uh was
contributing but also he like went to
these like big like screaming fits about
it like i said
dude to this era drama queens
uh you know they just couldn't they
couldn't
handle it they just couldn't even
thinking about a woman with eyes instead
of nipples and he was just like
he just couldn't even and he just
started screaming look he's still in
that damn yeah she pookie just curled up
in the sink and went to sleep and was
like [ __ ] it
so yeah so percy shelly is just like
apparently runs screaming from the room
according to some accounts i don't know
if he actually did this i don't know if
it was this dramatic or if he was just
like oh my god i can't take it but yeah
i can't take this vision anymore so yeah
so it that's kind of freaked him out
like i said drugs probably didn't help
you know what i mean
uh so yeah so at this point lord byron
is like okay well those stories are
pretty scary
but i'm paraphrasing
let's see we're all writers but you know
more or less here
let's see
who can write the best ghost story so he
essentially did like proposed a contest
we're all gonna come up with our own
scary story our own ghost story and
we'll see if we can like
do these ones one better
so let's see what we can come up with so
there's a whole like [ __ ]
con you know it's a whole [ __ ]
contest
now at this point mary shelley like i
said she's only 18 or 19 years old at
this stage
and she is
you know sharing air with percy shelley
you know poet although he like i said
he's not as famous as he was nowadays
but he's still kind of well known lord
byron obviously a lot better well-known
so
you know she's kind of like a feels i
kind of feel like she felt like maybe
she was a little intimidated
so she was kind of like well i have to
come up with like the bestest ghost
story ever like that's gonna scare the
[ __ ] out of like make them [ __ ] their
pants because
you know they're these big like literary
geniuses and i'm just mary shelley so i
really need to come up with something
[ __ ] good but it took a really long
time she couldn't think of anything
right um and she was just like and she
kept saying and she write about this
like later on
i think it was like in the preface of
like one of the later editions of
frankenstein where she was saying that
every morning like at breakfast they'd
be like oh did you come up with anything
yet and she just couldn't think of
anything she just couldn't think of
anything because she wanted it to be
like really really awesome but she
couldn't think of anything
now i will say though that
i think maybe
that she was the only person
that took this whole ghost story contest
thing like super seriously because
her [ __ ] was pretty much the only one
that like survived i mean all of them
survived obviously because all the
people were famous but hers was the only
one that endured like throughout the
ages although you could be arguing like
it could be argued that john polidoris
was but he might have ripped his [ __ ]
off from byron so
i'll get into that a little bit later
so mary shelley um you know she just
like couldn't think of anything couldn't
think of anything meanwhile
uh the thing that byron wrote uh
was he uh kind of started working on it
like i said i kind of feel like him and
percy sort of half-assed the whole
situation they did write some stuff but
it wasn't anything like earth-shattering
the thing that byron wrote ended up
being to this day it's probably it's
either called fragment of a novel i've
also seen it called the burial
um but i will say even though it's not
even a whole story like he didn't
[ __ ] finish the thing
but
it is one of the first vampire stories
in english literature interestingly
byron came up with uh but he didn't
finish it
now interestingly polidori who was his
personal physician and hanger on and
drug supplier allegedly
um
also allegedly
took the idea from lord byron's
unfinished story which you can still
read like on gutenberg and whatever like
public domain sites everywhere
um he took that idea and turned it into
essentially like a penny dreadful novel
called the vampire with a y
uh which many people have speculated was
one of the inspirations for bram
stoker's dracula so it could be
that lord byron
in his sort of half-assed i'm kind of
writing a ghost story but not really
because i'm not even gonna bother to
[ __ ] finish the thing
but he wrote a vampire story which
was one of the first ones in the english
language
uh which john polidori then allegedly
ripped off uh and made like a very
popular penny dreadful about it which
again bram stoker probably read because
everyone did
and later turned into dracula so it
could be that indirectly uh this
gathering also led to dracula could be
so you know we're saying and also uh the
the main vampire in
politori's
the vampire uh lord ruthvin was probably
based on byron so you know
there's that whole thing i've actually
read the fragment
uh
and it's you know it's it's pretty good
but yeah it's a vampire story
percy shelly half-assed it even more the
only [ __ ] he came up with at least i
think he wrote some other [ __ ] during
this time period too because they were
there the whole summer
but the only thing that he came up with
i think in regards to the ghost story
contest
was
something called a fragment of a ghost
story which was essentially like an
eight-line poem which like i said you
can still read it on wikipedia or
whatever but again very half-assed so
so mary was kind of the only one that
sort of took it seriously
and so she like overthought it because
that's well you know that's how she did
so she's like okay well i have to come
up with something really really good but
she couldn't think of anything for a
really long time
but then one night
um you know a few days after the
challenge had been posed
had
a very you know in hindsight very famous
nightmare
she had a nightmare
in which and this is the quote that she
came up with and she wrote this in later
editions of frankenstein this was the
dream that she had
she said when i placed my head on the
pillow i did not sleep nor could i be
said to think my imagination unbidden
possessed and guided me
i saw the pale student of unhallowed
arts kneeling beside the thing he had
put together
i saw the hideous phantasm of a man
stretched out and then upon the workings
of some powerful engine saw signs of
life so she had a nightmare about a dude
building somebody out of corpses and
bringing it to life because like i said
that was kind of
an idea that she'd been fascinated with
like pretty much throughout her entire
life and like i said there was all this
kind of like galvanism and all that kind
of stuff going on like bringing corpses
back to life and that was something that
obsessed her i don't know if i'd say
obsessed her but it was like something
that she was interested in and like i
said it could be too that because
uh you know her first baby had died uh
maybe she that even like uh you know
kind of strengthened her interest
because she was kind of like well she
was interested in like bringing the dead
back to life obviously i got a delivery
at the front door oh okay i wonder what
that is
at this time of night no it's not
earlier oh okay cause i was gonna say
it's 8 30.
so so yes so she has this horrible
horrible nightmare um
but to her credit she wakes up the next
morning and she's like oh all right i
got an idea i got a really good idea for
a story
uh and she's gonna base it on this
[ __ ] nightmare about a dude
like i think her dream was kind of more
like an alchemist type of thing but yeah
putting a body together into corpses and
like bringing it to life so she started
writing
a short story now essentially that's all
this was going to be i don't think i
don't know because like i said she was
only about 19 at this time
so i don't know if she wanted anything
more
than
just writing a scary ghost story that
would
impress shelly and byron because she
wanted i don't know i kind of feel like
she wanted to impress them because she
felt like they were maybe
i mean she had written before but she
hadn't like
she wasn't a writer you know she'd never
been published or anything and she was
very young still
so i kind of feel like she was
kind of on the hook to
okay you want me to wait until you're
done
you're making a lot of noise
that's it
okay handlebar weights
okay so so yeah so i kind of feel like
there was a lot of pressure on her to
kind of come up with something and when
she had the stream she's like okay i'm
gonna write a story about this but i
don't know
because i kind of feel like at the point
she just wanted to like write a scary
story so i don't know if she actually
had any ambitions for it other than it
just being like a scary short story
because that's all it was like to start
with
now interestingly like i said a lot of
themes of her life
if you read frankenstein and you read
her biography you can kind of see a lot
of her like the [ __ ] that happened in
her life like coming out in the story
one thing that comes out a lot in
frankenstein is that she really believed
she uh had similar views to her parents
but i think her parents were like a lot
more individualist than her she was kind
of more
she was an individualist too but she was
much more into like
um
you know
the rights of women and their compassion
and that compassion was kind of be like
humanity's savior type of thing and that
was gonna be
you know and that was gonna come mostly
from women
so she was also a big advocate of
every child that's born should be
wanted and loved
so
i kind of feel like one of the main
things in frankenstein is and one of the
main sins of dr frankenstein is that he
creates something and he's a man so he
can't have a baby so he has to like
cobble something together out of corpses
and bring it to life
um and then when it doesn't do what he
wants he abandons it like he abandons
his creation
and to her that was kind of like
that seemed like the main sin that he
had abandoned what he had made what
she's talking about because that was
like her child it's like his child
talking about those orphans out of
wedlock is what you're talking about
yeah the orphanages makes sense
so yeah that's the kind of thing and
it's just kind of like
and dr frankenstein is portrayed as i
mean he's kind of like a villain and
honestly the monster is portrayed more
sympathetically he's only
the monster is only a monster she calls
him a creature at first he's only a
monster because people treat him badly
because he looks [ __ ] up
and so her big thing in the novel was
that if you treat people badly they're
gonna lash out so it's almost kind of
like she doesn't really
in the text she seems to like not blame
the monster for his and the monster
seems to say this too he's like look i'm
only like doing all this [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and killing people because everyone was
like shitty to me which
that was kind of like one thing that
she's you're like look you treat people
shitty they're gonna be shitty you know
what i mean you like carl fans around
yeah so it's so yeah that was so she was
kind of like kind of making a statement
about that
and like i said it was also kind of a
thing where she was almost i don't know
if she was villainizing dr frankenstein
for
trying to
i don't know she she was kind of like
atheistic so i don't think she was like
dr frankenstein like usurping god's
power but it's almost kind of like he
was usurping
the power of life because he couldn't
give birth to a child so he just like
made one
out of corpses
um and then when it did some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] he like abandoned it or he you know
what i mean he wouldn't like take care
of it as soon as he saw like quote
unquote how monstrous it was he wasn't
it didn't come out the way he wanted
like it wasn't beautiful like he thought
it would be so he's like man [ __ ] that
[ __ ] as a man you can't physically make
other people but you can make machines
men love machines you build a [ __ ]
yeah motorcycle what if there's
something to that that's really
interesting well yeah of course there is
because you can't like create you can't
create it so you create machines and
create systems and you create this and
that so
yeah of course yeah so there was a lot
of that so i kind of feel like mary
probably put a lot of herself or a lot
of her own sympathies into the creature
because even though he kills people and
[ __ ] like that i mean he only does that
because he's ostracized
because he's monstrous
so
and i think like i said one of the
things i think that's something that the
movies got right is that they made him
even though he kills people he's still
like sympathetic because everyone's so
shitty tim that like you understand
because he just you know he just wants
to be
himself you know and then there's the
whole thing too where he asks dr
frankenstein to make him a bride because
he's alone
and then dr frankenstein's like okay and
he thinks about it and basically he's
like well i'm going to kill everybody in
your family if you don't make me a bride
but then he doesn't do it so then the
monster just like kills everybody just
like he said he was going to yeah it's
like something out of a damn morsi
album but yeah so you can really see i
mean like i said this is i am the sun
and the air
but yeah so so as i said so she just
wrote this as a short story
um apparently like they thought it was
really cool although like i said it kind
of feels like by the time she finished
the story
um byron and shelly are kind of
half-assed it like i said polidori wrote
the vampire but that was later like he
kind of like expanded that out later
from
an idea that he allegedly ripped off
from byron so that was kind of like
later on but like yeah mary shelley just
wrote a short story at the time so she
probably didn't think all that much
about it
until a little bit later on
so uh at this
point uh so they spend the summer there
that should happen she writes the short
story percy apparently like is really
into it and he's like really supportive
he's like wow this is really good so
then they go back to london
um and she kind of continues writing
because apparently percy said hey this
is really good you should expand this
into a novel because at the time it was
only like a short story so she started
working on that now at this point they
still have the baby william
um and
uh notably in the novel frankenstein um
dr frankenstein has a younger brother
also named william who spoiler alert the
monster kills later on
uh you know
so
basically when they go back to london
um
mary's older
half sister fanny
uh ended up committing suicide
now
mary was really really upset about this
because fannie i guess she'd kind of
always been like overshadowed by mary
and mary felt
guilty that she could have done more to
like be more in her life and like talk
to her more and she kind of felt like
she'd neglected her and she was like
responsible for her killing herself so
that was like another death that she
felt like was almost like on her hands
kind of because like i said even as a
kid
she felt responsible for her mom's death
because her mom had died like after she
gave birth to her so she's like all
these deaths are kind of like
she feels responsible for all of them so
her older half sister dies and she feels
responsible for that as well she uh
killed herself now mary
um
also i guess
like i said
mary had she had kind of inherited this
depressive
temperament i guess you'd call it from
her mom because her mom had also
attempted suicide a couple of times she
was very you know she was suffer from
depression as well and mary seems to
have also suffered from that and
like i said she seemed um to feel very
responsible for bad things that happened
around her which like i said that's
that's very common for people with that
temperament
uh two months later after fannie
committed suicide her uh half-sister
um
shelley's wife
harriet who he had abandoned
uh she was 21 at the time she also
killed herself she actually jumped off a
[ __ ] bridge
into the serpentine which is a lake in
hyde park in london she was eight months
pregnant so she had jumped off a thing
because shelly had abandoned her uh with
some kids left her all alone and so she
killed herself also
so mary also probably understandably
felt responsible for that as well
shelley didn't really seem to give a
[ __ ] because that's kind of how he
rolled so you know
shelley's story this is i love this
percy shelley
i think one of the reasons that he was
able to not feel bad about his wife
harriet because they were still i guess
legally married at this point
even though he had run off with mary
um
he didn't really seem to feel all that
bad about it because he's like oh well
what happened with that was that um
after i left
she got like kicked out of her dad's
house and then she
uh went to a she went and worked in a
brothel which i'm not entirely sure is
true and then she ran off with some
other dude and that other dude deserted
her and that's why she killed herself so
it totally wasn't me
that's kind of yeah so he's kind of like
absolving himself of responsibility
which like i said typical of this type
of dude but you know so like i said i
love trying to get it i love your
problems and everything but you know
he's he wasn't as big as [ __ ] as lord
byron but he was still kind of a [ __ ]
most of these dudes just trying to get
all this [ __ ] behind them so they can
climb up into some more booty
that's what i'm saying
they don't really they don't give a
single goddamn [ __ ] about anybody other
than themselves and their own penises
yeah and they're basically like how
women want to put it like no i'm just no
i'm just saying that's kind of like
[ __ ] man's on a mission you know a
man's on a mission he's just trying to
get through life and have a good time
and
he doesn't want to hear any of this
drama
well like i said because they don't have
to like bear any of the brunt of the
fallout
of their actions
well yeah they just want to do [ __ ]
without consequences um and a lot of
times and particularly during this time
period they didn't really have to bear
any of the consequences so they didn't
really worry about it no the the man
mafia was in charge right
so yeah so his wife uh basically jumped
off a bridge uh eight months pregnant
and drowned herself
and uh so he was basically like well
some other dude abandoned her and so it
wasn't my fault that's right kind of
what his story was yeah made excuses for
it yeah uh so uh right so at this point
like mary still has uh william their son
uh and at this point too she's also
pregnant
uh with a third one
claire at this point was pregnant too
they're not sure this is probably
byron's kid
but it could have been shelley's kid no
one's entirely sure most people think it
was probably byron's kid because they
were [ __ ] at this point i think like
percy and claire were probably [ __ ]
too
but
everybody most people agree this is
probably byron's kid that she was
pregnant with at this point
um
but byron was like no it was totally
shelly so like i said everybody's trying
to like absolve themselves as a
responsibility they don't they want free
love but they don't want the
consequences of it all right
is what i'm saying would you well i'm a
woman so it's like i know they're i know
there are consequences
i'm not stupid enough to fake the point
there would you select no consequences i
think there aren't just select
consequences it goes no consequences you
select well everybody would do that but
like i said that's not how the world
works
and like i said because i'm a woman i
understand that there are consequences
of things um oh you're saying men don't
understand the consequences they don't
really see of course i mean they act as
a strength they acted right now we know
because they don't have to like do
anything so like i said they don't they
don't have to like get fat and like for
nine months and do all that [ __ ] so yeah
well you can get the pill you know what
i mean you can [ __ ] or you're right
but that doesn't work rhythm
that doesn't work all the time though
that's not 100 if nothing's 100
effective except for absolutely right
and nobody wants that [ __ ] sake okay
so so yeah um so basically what happens
is that
um
at this stage because mary and percy had
a kid
and even though percy was kind of dead
set against marriage in principle
and mary was not a big fan of it i mean
at least in principle like i said uh
they figured well probably we should get
married at this point because if we have
any more kids it's like in case there's
custody issues there was legal issues so
they thought probably they should get
married so like i said at this point
they actually did get married so during
the whole like summer
of 1816 they were not actually married
but they did actually marry like later
that year uh even though they were
technically both against it but like i
said for legal reasons they decided to
now when they got married interestingly
um mary's dad who like i said they'd
kind of been estranged uh since for a
couple of years since she had run off
with percy so
he actually did come to her wedding and
they actually did like reconcile uh
after this although the relationship i
don't think was ever as close as it had
been prior to that because i kind of
feel like
he thought maybe she like disappointed
him and it was kind of like that sort of
thing but he was sort of happy about it
so they kind of like made up so that was
nice so she kind of got back into her
like dad's good graces or whatever
um so yeah
so they get married in late 1816.
now interestingly though it's kind of
like
so summer of 1817 was like a year later
as i said frankenstein started as like a
short story but because percy thought it
was really good and like sort of
encouraged her like hey why don't you
make it a whole novel
so summer of 1817 mary shelley finishes
it
now
uh because
women were not really i mean nobody
really wanted to read anything that was
written by a woman
so a lot of women writers uh went by
male pseudonyms or published things
anonymously or under other people's
names or things like that
um which you know wasn't discovered so
much later so what ended up happening
was that
she published it in january of 1818
anonymously
but because there was a preface which
was written by percy shelley
and it was dedicated to william godwin
who was murray shelley's father
everyone assumed that frankenstein had
been written by percy shelley
because like i said nobody knew really
all that much about mary shelley like i
said women were not really i got to give
a shout out though what's that because
this reminds me of another story what's
that
there's this old black and white movie
called the ghost in mrs muir remember
that it's a love story between a living
woman and a damn ghost he was a [ __ ]
man of the sea
and part of the [ __ ] story was he was
a dick at first but they kind of [ __ ]
had this relationship going on with this
ghost and he ghost writes a story to her
about his tales of the sea and they had
i believe
they had to publish that under a male
suited them a lot of women did back then
yeah but she was able to make enough
money to buy the house
yeah which used to be his house if you
guys never seen that old black and white
movie called that's a good movie i liked
it ghost and mrs muir i haven't
mentioned it on the show ever before bad
ass flick
it's a good [ __ ]
ghost movie
but also kind of like a romantic drama
pretty cool tear-jerking at the end
don't spoil it yeah no no no i remember
that movie movie good movie yeah we
haven't seen a long time we gotta watch
that again we should actually yeah yeah
that's a good one it's a classic classic
but yeah that was something that
happened a lot like women like women did
write novels obviously but they usually
published anonymously or under
a male pseudonym that's kind of how you
got around the [ __ ]
um so yeah even though she published it
anonymously everyone just assumed that
percy shelly had written it because he
was kind of like well known he was a man
and he had written the preface now uh it
was only much later that it came out
like that mary shelley had actually
written it now even to this day scholars
still debate
how much influence percy shelley had
over the novel although i will say that
there were i guess like in there's a
collection in england um that had like
this like the original manuscript and it
actually has like percy shelley's like
notes and [ __ ] and apparently
um basically what his role was he was
just like a line editor pretty much he
just like went through the story and
like made little corrections and [ __ ]
like that so i don't think that he
really had all that much influence over
the final story i think that was mostly
her but you know he just may
basically do like little editorial [ __ ]
so you know that there's that whole
thing because i kind of feel like for a
long time people were like oh percy
shelly actually wrote it or whatever he
did not she wrote it uh he just did like
some editing duties now at first
uh they only printed 500 copies
which doesn't sound like a lot but those
500 copies
apparently fell into the hands of very
very like influential like all the kind
of big literary lights of the time
everybody was reading this [ __ ] as soon
as it came out
it was kind of like a sensation you have
to think that this was like essentially
the first
i don't know if it was the first but it
was like the first widespread science
fiction story
really
um sci-fi
yeah and
so it was something that a lot of people
it's not like completely original
because nothing it is nothing is but
it's kind of like they hadn't really
seen anything like this before so as
soon as it came out even though it was
very very limited edition
all of the people like influential
people in society were reading it like
everybody was reading this [ __ ] and
everybody was talking about it like in
the literary circles and stuff so it was
like an immediate sensation pretty much
um
so it basically it's kind of like all
right so at this point
uh you know the book's doing well as far
as i know i don't think anybody at this
point knows that mary shelley wrote it
yet it's just still like anonymous
people are assuming it's percy shelly
nobody's really saying anything about it
um mary has another baby a baby girl
named clara
um and at this point too claire
claremont also gives birth to a kid who
is probably byron's
uh and this is a daughter named allegra
um she was actually named abra for our
alba at first but then they called her
allegra later on
happiness
you're happy you got your allegra means
happiness it does
uh so yeah we're
all happy so with this they're telling
me to put the [ __ ] mullet on oh okay
tom put the wallet on okay there you go
you do look nice in the mullet yeah you
look like joe you look like joe dirt
yeah
get ready get rid of the country western
music and [ __ ] okay well you can't seem
like i'm almost i'm almost to the bottom
okay
so uh all right so at this point they
they go to italy after claire has the
kid
because claire however misguidedly
thinks well i'm going to take here's our
daughter like me and byron's daughter so
i'm going to take our daughter
to byron
and it'll
i don't know what she was expecting
um
but as i said before lord byron kind of
a dick
apparently what happens they go to italy
which is you know where byron was living
at the time
and uh basically byron writes a letter
and says yeah i'm going to send somebody
to collect quote unquote the brat
and um
i'm just gonna take the kid and claire
should never see me or speak to me or
see the kid ever again
so you know a little bit of a dick just
saying
uh so byron essentially takes allegra
from claire the mother
and uh pokes her in a convent
a baby puts her convent
allegra ended up dying
uh five years later probably of typhus
maybe malaria not entirely sure yeah oh
that [ __ ] water that was nice yeah so
she so he didn't want the baby he just
took the baby away from her
and stuck it in a convent and said
you're not allowed to see the baby
anymore just for whatever reason because
i'm a douche and whatever so you know
that's nice
so dude's a dick yeah he's a giant dick
um
now at this point uh
so percy shelly for whatever reason is
still friends with this douche because
they i mean like i said personally is
kind of an issue he was he was just like
a a lesser douche
in the douche
you know taxonomy of douches he's like a
lesser douche
it's hard to be as much of a douche as
lord byron but yeah so shelley was kind
of up there too uh so they're kind of
still hanging out together
so him and claire go and stay with lord
byron uh in padua where he was staying
in italy
now
mary at this point like i said she had
had another baby at this point in clara
uh and the baby was sick
but mary took uh you know because she
kind of took a coach journey she didn't
like shake [ __ ] or anything but like
overland and it was like a long journey
and they were both kind of sick but she
went there to join them
um
but
three weeks after arriving
uh to see byron
clara the baby
also died of dysentery damn so how many
is this this is minnie's like drinking
more of that [ __ ] water
oh goodness they didn't know about clean
water back then i guess not like
everybody's like [ __ ] babies like
dropping [ __ ] dead i can't believe
i don't know i guess it's like [ __ ]
no wonder [ __ ] barry was [ __ ]
depressed all the time holy crap every
baby she's had has like [ __ ] died
so uh so yeah so she's had it so
obviously she's very upset
um but the book frankenstein is going
gag busters man uh everybody's like say
everybody's reading this [ __ ]
everybody's talking about it even back
then
like only like a year or two after it
was published
um you know people talk about now like
you know the universal horror movie
cycles and stuff and how like they made
the serious ones and they made like the
funny ones and [ __ ] like that even back
then they were doing stage adaptations
of it they were like comedies so you
know only like a year or two after it
was uh published so it was like a
massive like cultural sensation even at
the time so you know so that's nothing
new
so uh so yeah everybody's [ __ ]
reading this it's all over the [ __ ]
cultural zeitgeist of the time
uh
and also so like i said she still has
this is 1819. uh mary still has her son
william who like i said she loves more
than anybody because like i said her
other two kids have died
uh but sadly god this is so [ __ ] up
uh william
also started to get sick around this
time gets a fever
uh and he um
basically uh ended up dying also malaria
he died of malaria at three years old
uh at this point mary is just she can't
[ __ ] tell i mean understandably like
i said every kid she's had has died
and not just in like when they were
babies but sometimes when they were
older
uh and she just like can't [ __ ] take
it anymore and she starts getting to a
point where
she's
depressed all the time and she starts
according to like a lot of her friends
and stuff she basically starts like
emotionally
just shutting down everybody said she
came very cold and very distant
because which like i said is very
understandable because she's lost so
many of the people that she loved that
she's basically like look i'm just gonna
shut off all my emotions she can't
control anything to keep yeah just to
keep from
just being wallowed in [ __ ] grief all
the time because how that can't be fun
for anybody how old is she at this point
um
18 19 she's like 20. so real young still
yeah yeah um yeah so like i said it's
it's [ __ ] terrible so
the thing about percy though like i said
not as big a dick as lord byron but
still kind of a dick
all percy worried about
was he wasn't all like honey i
understand your pain you know i'm there
for you i'm supportive because it was
his kids too i mean it's not like it was
just her right
but he was basically more worried about
well you're just a bummer to hang around
with right yeah you're a drag yeah
basically that was basically this he
didn't say that but like he wrote some
poems and i'm reading the poems that he
wrote about her at this time period and
i'm like dude do you even care about
anybody other than yourself it's like
all he cared about was you're not the
woman that you used to be i'm like yeah
can you blame her holy crap
and it's just kind of like that's all he
cared about was i just want that woman
back even though like he didn't really
seem to care about the kids at all and
she really like that really resonated
with her because it seemed like he was
just like bouncing back like oh well
kids are dead let's just like continue
on
and he expected her to do that too and
she couldn't do that in those days they
did die a lot they did but it's just
kind of like
um
it's a little uh it's a little
cold to just i can understand i can
understand kind of like both sides of
that argument
you got a woman who's just devastated by
all this [ __ ] damage that has
happened they don't really know why
children die at this point so you might
blame yourself
but they don't know that you can't drink
dirty water well that's what i mean
and mary had the kind of personality
that she would absolutely blame herself
what did i do wrong she blamed herself
for her mother dying yeah even though
she was only 11 days old you don't
really know
there's no such thing as anapha
antibiotics or uh you know medical
science as you know it
so you tend to probably think well god
did this or the universe did this or you
know so
i can kind of now the other now the
other guy the on the other hand he asked
me he's a little bit sociopathic
yeah that's kind of that's the word i
would use that's the way he's kind of
like well [ __ ] happens man [ __ ] shake
it off deal with it yeah we'll do it
we'll do it again and basically all he
worried about was and he said this like
in a more poetic language in one of the
things but he's basically saying you're
not getting my dick card anymore right
yeah you're so i'm losing interest
because
oh my gosh you're sad because you're
babies well you have to understand
something first of all they're primitive
people this was a long time ago they
don't have full knowledge they're also
very they're also young
and they don't really understand
the difference between the way it is in
their time and what it could be
they don't you know what i mean they
don't know
it's [ __ ] up but they don't understand
why it's [ __ ] up
or how they play into that yeah you know
uh they
so therefore they probably tended to
blame themselves
yeah and like i said this is a
generalization but when bad [ __ ] happens
women generally tend to be like what did
i do wrong to cause this
and mary seems to have that exact
personality everything that happened
everybody that died every bad thing that
happened she thought she felt like
personally responsible well
for not doing more the deaths that
you're talking about are usually related
to things like poor sanitation bad water
right but they wouldn't have known they
would have known not really
okay
so i mean she blamed herself for her
older half sister committing suicide
because she's like why wasn't i there
more
why was it why didn't i why wasn't i
there to support her why wouldn't you
know i could have helped her i did not
know enough to really understand why
mortality rate was high
yeah
so it is kind of funny when you look
back in a certain way it was just just
sad that uh that people like this and i
would call these these were not modern
people okay they just really weren't
they had modern thinking but they're not
in a modern situation
and yeah they had high mortality
nothing we can do about it now yeah and
i mean you can just have some sympathy
for them like yeah
well it was out as outside of your hands
yeah but you're going to look at us like
that too i mean you know i feel bad for
her and honestly i kind of wish
she's mary shelley is one of those
people that i wish i could go back in a
time machine and like bring her to the
modern era
and show her
how much her work has impacted
the culture because maybe that would
cheer her up a little bit because i kind
of feel like she needed some cheering up
i mean it's the same thing with even
later on i mean friedrich nietzsche
[ __ ] mentioned about time when he was
on the in the german scene
hanging out with this cool chick that he
was [ __ ] he wanted to hit
you know and she was bubbly and fun and
[ __ ] but she had tb
and you know what i mean she was
coughing up blood and you know
her days were numbered yep and they
didn't know what tv was and they didn't
have a cure for it you know what i mean
yeah as soon as she went and blood came
up everybody's like well
yeah let's start making a coffin for you
he said she was smart and cute as a bug
and didn't last long though she died a
lot of people did
and
you know you can kind of go back in time
mentally and try to picture yourself you
know what i've done or what would that
have been like
it would have been exactly what you're
reading about you've seen you watched
all these people get sick and died or
you'd sit there helplessly yeah that
wasn't anything there's nothing you
could do and like i said because they
weren't entirely cognizant of what was
going on
like i said it would be very easy if you
were already of that you know
personality or that bent that
you would kind of blame yourself like
what could i have done to prevent that
you know i kind of feel like they
probably couldn't have in a lot of ways
it's the same thing though you know
these people they they didn't live very
long back then and that was just the way
of things
sad it is a lot of people went through
it but there's no we can't help them
that's what i mean it's like it's so
shitty that like people had to go
through that and like
live like this without knowing that like
[ __ ] could be better here's the good
thing about it even if [ __ ] you know
what i mean the world were to fall apart
and [ __ ] society were to collapse it
would not go back to that level because
that because the knowledge is out there
well yeah like i'm saying so i'm not
really like yeah we're worried about
everything going like back to cave
mandates no it never goes it would never
go back that far it would go back
society-wise or organizationally the
1800s but the knowledge wouldn't go back
to the 1800s you'd still have technology
guys would be making guns there'd be
computers there'd probably be an
internet
you'd have the knowledge you'd know what
dysentery was you would know that to
filter water or at least boil it you
know and boil it and filter it if you
can
but there would be an infrastructure
because everyone would demand it
if there'd be a city that we're gonna
have a [ __ ] water supply yeah because
like i said everybody i kind of feel
like that knowledge has been descended
disseminated disseminated as too deeply
inside mankind yeah everybody knows hey
let's not drink [ __ ] water right that's
not a good idea yeah
yeah i'm pretty sure everybody knows
that yeah but yeah so uh so yeah so
percy is basically like why don't you
get my dick card anymore um you know
yeah the babies are dead get over it and
she's just kind of like what the [ __ ]
why is he such a douche it was it was
that kind of situation so they move out
to this house
uh called the villa marini which is kind
of like out in the middle of nowhere it
was like a coastal type of place which
shelley was like into that he was like
really into like the sea he was
seafaring all that kind of stuff so he
was into it mary couldn't stand it she
thought it was horrible so she was
miserable again like out there
but he didn't really give a [ __ ] about
that because you know he was all about
percy
uh so basically um
what happened
so mary has a fourth child at this point
was she named after him sadly percy uh
spoiler this is the only child of hers
that she had of five i think she had
five uh this was the only one that
survived into uh adulthood
um so mary at this point she's kind of
like have some illness and i think she's
pregnant again at this point she's only
24.
this is 1822.
uh percy like i said he's real into like
seafaring he's moved boats and
everything like that
so he has a friend and they go out he
has this new uh sailboat called the don
juan
and he goes out to visit byron in
livorno which was 65 miles uh away on
the coast of italy
so he goes off with his friend
and then nobody hears anything
for many many days
mary is starting to freak the [ __ ] out
where did percy go
so she goes her and claire go off to
livorno where byron was living and they
wait for him
uh what ended up happening three days
after they arrived there a
couple bodies wash up on the beach one
of them was percy shelley's he died when
he was 29 years old so he was like swept
off his boat in a storm
and he drowned
uh mary shelley was understandably again
[ __ ] devastated she's 24 her husband
is 29 and he's [ __ ] dead and she's
seen his body wash up on the [ __ ]
beach
uh basically because she didn't really i
guess she didn't really have to like
bury anybody or whatever because she
like burned his body they burned his
body like on the beach where he was
found and she actually kept part of his
heart they found it like in her stuff
like later on she had like a lock of his
hair and like a little bit of his heart
that she had taken and then just like
she had bro that's even unusual even
back in those days by 24 to see so many
deaths
that's what i'm saying it's just like
yeah it wasn't that crazy because like
yeah babies and stuff died and a lot of
her babies died well like i said only
one of her kids survived into adulthood
right um but yeah her mom died in
childbirth likes and percy died when he
was 29. 24 has still a baby that's yeah
which is crazy yeah i mean the poor the
god the poor [ __ ] woman yeah it's
[ __ ] crazy
so yeah so now percy was dead
um and she was again devastated
now interestingly like i said i feel
like she doesn't get enough credit
for her essentially being
percy's like pr person
after he died
because he was kind of known like in
literary circles but not like lord byron
famous
and lord byron
had actually never mentioned percy
really like in any of his writings
and mary asked him about that was like
dude what the [ __ ] um and then she kind
of made it like her life's mission
to get all of his stuff published and
get it out there so it's arguable
that would we even know who percy
shelley was
if it wasn't for her and the weird thing
is that for a long time afterward
uh mary shelley probably up until like
the late 80s at least in literary
circles was kind of known as oh that
girl that wrote frankenstein oh and
percy shelley's wife
um but like i said the irony is i don't
think percy shelley would be as well
known for his verse if she hadn't
advocated for his [ __ ] after he was dead
because she was like instrumental in
getting a lot of his [ __ ] published and
edited she edited all his stuff like
later and all that stuff what's funny is
that her personal story arc seems to end
at about 24.
it didn't though she lived until she was
53 and she wrote like a bunch of [ __ ]
after that okay which was not actually
appreciated until much after she was
dead everybody like was into
frankenstein
um you know and that kind of like
overshadowed a lot of her stuff and like
i said she got overshadowed by percy
shelley for a long time but how was it
appreciated in the 1800s
um
i kind of feel like famous and we forgot
she um she kind of was she made a living
right um she actually so she was well
known enough to like make a living from
her writing yeah and to clarify to the
audience think about it there were
celebrities through the 18th and the
1900s that were famous as [ __ ] in their
days you'd even know their names
for god and fame yeah actors that were
forgotten yeah [ __ ] some of them were
films some of them were [ __ ] stage
actors there were wildly famous you
would never even know
you know you they're you wouldn't even
recognize their names and authors
so was she something like that where in
her lifetime or maybe like uh the
generation after was she famous in the
18th i mean i think she was like she was
well known in in literary circles yeah
yeah
um
[Music]
you know you could be famous in those
days right no social media yeah so she
was well known yet and like i said she
was known enough to like make a living
at it and like i said she wrote several
novels several plays essays nonfiction
she wrote all kind of [ __ ] like
afterwards because she lived
quite a long time after percy shelley's
death although i don't
i mean she had some kind of like
flirtations and relationships and
apparently i mean she was quite
beautiful
so she did have a lot of gentlemen
callers and suitors and stuff like that
afterward but she seemed
not super into it it's like she kind of
she had a lot of friendships with men
later
um but
when she would have uh you know male
suitors a lot of really writers and
stuff like that like courted her
uh gave like marriage proposals she was
set high she always yeah she always kind
of turned him down for that reason she
was just kind of like look i was married
to one genius uh unless you were of the
same caliber as him i'm not having it
right um so there was that thing another
thing she did too i mean uh and i don't
know if a lot of people know this but
she was a big advocate like i said you
know her mom was like probably like the
first i don't know if she was the first
feminist but she was kind of like the
founder of feminism and so um
mary shelley was very into she kind of
put her money where her mouth was she
would help out women uh one particular
case i was reading about it on her
wikipedia page where there was a woman
that she knew who was a lesbian which
was really not
a kosher at that time
and she helped that woman like escape to
france
with her lover
um and they actually like she made it
like legally so the lover was like a man
even though it was a woman um so she
kind of like set it up so they could
live as like husband and wife even
though they were both women uh so she
was like very ahead of her time in that
regard she was very into like helping
women who were
you know down their luck or persecuted
for whatever reason because of their
alternative sexualities or whatever so
she actually did kind of do a lot of
[ __ ] in that line and she wrote a lot
about that too like later on but i kind
of some rare [ __ ] either there was a lot
of women like that throughout history
well it just wasn't super acceptable
going back to the roman period yeah and
some of them were [ __ ] bad too you
know countess bathory straight up
[ __ ] lesbian well she was a serious
murderer yeah
i don't know if she killed as many
people as people a tribute to her what
do they say who knows how much of that
is true but i don't know purportedly
some of that might be haters like after
she was dead
it's hard to say someone said it was all
made up they were just trying to steal
her land
but uh which could happen i mean that
did happen but there were some there
there's some um memoirs this [ __ ] and
left behind that the romanians have in
the vault and uh there was some witness
testimony though the investigators went
there and said no they were
dead girls inside of cages and [ __ ]
bad [ __ ] yeah i'm not saying and we did
a show on her but i was just kind of
saying i don't you know i i don't think
she killed 600 people but i'm not saying
that she didn't kill anybody i would
yeah i remember that
i i think 600 is an exaggeration but i
think it's an exaggeration i do think
she was a zero 50 60 70 probably yeah i
mean which is bad enough like i said
that's bad enough on its own she was
still absolutely a serial killer yeah
but i do think that people like
exaggerated [ __ ] over the years yeah
um but yeah so
basically mary shelley
um like i said uh percy died when she
was 24
and she spent a lot of her time later i
mean she made a living from her writing
so obviously she was famous enough for
that she was actually like able to make
a living at it she wrote a lot of novels
she actually wrote an apocalyptic novel
called the last man in 1826 so again
kind of ahead of her time just saying uh
and read a lot she did like a lot of
editing like i said she uh edited a lot
of um collections of percy's work so the
rest of her life she really devoted a
lot of her life too to not only her own
writing but advocating for percy's uh
verse and whatever so she did actually
do a lot of that
and she wrote like travel books
[ __ ] like that uh so she kept herself
busy uh also like i said very into her
political causes feminism all that kind
of stuff and as i said actually did
help women on the ground that were
trying to like you know get out of
[ __ ] situations that were not uh
acceptable at the time
so she did actually uh do that and uh
it's just interesting so she ended up
dying
in 1851 she was 53 years old uh her
physician suspected it was probably a
brain tumor um she had suffered from uh
pretty bad like ill health through the
last few years of her life
um you know like i said kind of a
melancholy woman but she did kind of
you know she did kind of like
still be around like society and stuff
but i don't she didn't marry again she
didn't do any of that kind of stuff she
didn't kind of like have relationships
but
yeah and like i said i think that percy
was her great love
and
everybody else she had a lot of male
friends but i don't think anything ever
lived up to that for her right and so
she just wasn't having it um so you know
there was that whole thing but she's a
really interesting
uh she's a really interesting person i
always found her an interesting person
but uh yeah all right well i guess
that's the end of the show we covered it
yeah all right go ahead and shut it down
and i mean just think about but like i
said think about how
just something she came up with because
of a contest
is now like everybody knows that [ __ ]
book
everybody being first has a lot to do
yeah yeah and think about how many
[ __ ] movies have been made about it
think about look at look i even have
like a frankenstein right there like a
little model of frankenstein i don't
know if you know where that character's
not the same character that she was kind
of talking about in the books actually
it's not there's there were several
different interpretations of frankfurt
well in the novel the monster the
creature kind of sympathetic
he was sympathetic and he could talk
yeah
like after a while like he escaped and
then like he found all these books and
like he kind of like hung out with
people and like he learned to talk and
he was really like articulate from what
i remember the [ __ ] um the the robert
de niro version was closer to what i
remember yeah that actually the the
kenneth branagh directed one uh is
actually the closest one to the book
that i've ever seen yeah i'm not saying
and i love the universal ones like the
old ones like with boris karloff but
those are but that's not what the book
was yeah that's like that's only like a
tiny little part of the story yeah and
the fact that the creature is like in
arts he's still sympathetic but he's
inarticulate like he can't talk and
stuff that is not at all like the book
yeah in the book he was like flowery
yeah he was like a super philosopher
yeah it was like this whole [ __ ]
because she like i said she was making a
statement about
the doctor like his sin being
he had created
essentially a child but because he
wasn't a woman he couldn't have a child
naturally so he had to build one of
corporates also was an insult against
god yeah and he brought it to life uh
artificially and then he immediately
abandoned it because it didn't come out
the way he expected it to yeah uh so
to her that was like his greatest sin i
guess was that he abandoned his creation
and uh that was kind of like a big thing
for her but yeah there's like all kind
of philosophical like i said go like
read her [ __ ] she's a fascinating
fascinating person
and we just like kind of scratched the
surface
um because i feel like even nowadays
like all she's known for is frankenstein
which is good you know but she wrote
like a bunch of other [ __ ] too and she's
like really interesting but yeah so uh
sorry we kind of our [ __ ] kind of like
cut off in the middle but at least we
have a part two going so yeah so i guess
we'll uh kind of shut it down for the
evening
and i might have one more drink it's
okay
and uh you know so we'll see you guys
friday night and friday night we'll have
some more drinks we'll do a sidetrack
show yeah we'll talk about some [ __ ]
whatever it is that we talk about we'll
come up with it at the time
tomorrow we might go see halloween kills
we'll see how it goes dunes coming up
too
yeah actually dune starts well it
probably starts tomorrow night or friday
so i don't know we'll see because we're
so i mean we're still paying for that
[ __ ] stubbsy list thing so we might
as well go see some free [ __ ] movies
just saying all right so thanks
everybody for dropping by this evening
for this topic that i'm gonna want to do
for a really long time i love this kind
of [ __ ] uh so yeah remember like share
subscribe all that kind of stuff and we
will see you guys again on friday night
thanks for dropping by thanks for super
chats we'll see you then
bye